it's almost time for yet another
Republican presidential primary debate I
thought it would be a good opportunity
to look back at some of the highlights
from the debate so far but the first
thing we have to do is talk about who's
running let's get to that first
as far as the wall is concerned we're
going to build a wall we're going to
create a border and Mexico is going to
pay for the wall we need to keep
illegals out
we need a significantly changed taxation
system based on tithing because I think
God's pretty fair guy
if you want someone to grab a beer with
I may not be that guy but if you want
someone to drive you home I will get the
job done
I know that the world is a safer and
better place when America is the
strongest military power in the world
I brought my own water I've been singled
out for criticism our view economic ahna
me for everybody people have a chance
the fiscal irresponsibility the failures
approach the right one canceling the
state dinner
they call me vito corleone e because i
veto 2500 separate line items in the
budget
I vetoed more tax increases than any
governor in American history
according to americans for tax reform
I may not be your dream candidate just
yet but I can assure you I'm Hillary
Clinton's worst nightmare
folks we all know you can't pick them up
and ship them across back across the
border it's a silly argument
I want a government so small I can
barely see it
there is no role at the federal level
for the Department of Education and I'm
still one who says that we can get rid
of the Internal Revenue Service first
we've heard all sorts of crazy tax plans
from a number of these candidates let's
take a look at the ideas each of them
had on taxation if you give me a tithe
it doesn't matter how much you made if
you've had a bumper crop you don't owe
me triple x and you've had no crops at
all you don't owe me no time so there
must be something inherently fair about
that $15 hole you also have to do some
strategic cutting you'd have to cut
government by about 40 percent to make
it work what the 1.1 trillion dollars I
think we ought to get rid of all the
taxes on people who produce and it's why
I am an unabashed supporter of the Fair
Tax which would be a tax on our
consumption rather than a tax on our
productivity in other words you're not
going to tax anybody or what they earn
whether it's a worker who's working by
the hour or whether it's a hedge fund
manager so that's why I've chosen to get
rid of the whole thing and have one
single rate fourteen and a half percent
for everybody business and for corporate
in corporate income and personal income
but we also get rid of the payroll tax
through tax reform we'll pass a simple
flat tax and abolish the IRS and Bernie
Sanders will tell them that it's because
of the rich well I'll tell you something
you can take everything from the top one
percent and you apply it to our fiscal
gap and you won't even make a dent in it
you know these plans would put us
trillions and trillions of dollars in
debt this stuff is fantasy just like
getting rid of Medicare and Medicaid
said yesterday and that's just not you
look scare senior citizens with that
it's not responsible
abortion is always an interesting topic
especially in Republican debates and
there is no shortage of opinions about
abortion from this year's suite of
candidates it's time that we recognize
the Supreme Court is not the Supreme
Being I am pro-life murdering millions
of babies I hate the concept of abortion
I hate the concept of abortion and what
I have advocated is that we pass law in
this country that says all human life at
every stage of its development is worthy
of protection whether they can vote or
not
to open an investigation into these
videos and a prosecute Planned
Parenthood for any criminal violations
and protect children instead of rip up
their body parts and sell them like
their parts to a Buick there's never a
lost opportunity during Republican
debates to bash either Democrats Hillary
Clinton or President Obama and we've
been seeing that so far that's for sure
this nation's possibilities and
potential are being crushed you know I
see a socialist and isolationist and a
pessimist and for this for the sake of
me I can't figure out which one is which
lying about Benghazi of lying about her
emails about lying about her servers she
does not have a track record of
accomplishment as a sort of break from
slamming Democrats Hillary Clinton and
Barack Obama we also saw Republican
candidates during the debates attack the
moderators the questions that have been
asked so far in this debate illustrate
why the American people don't trust the
media had a chance let me pick a part
it's not a very nicely asked question
the way you say that in its last debate
I'm gonna get my question you're not
interested in an answer although he's
not going to be the eventual nominee and
he's been a force that has led to the
Republican Party appearing even more
foolish and ridiculous than you and I
might have imagined Donald Trump has
been if nothing else really entertaining
during these debates you know I think
mr. Trump is a wonderful entertainer but
I do think one second no I do not take
more energy tonight I like that
but then his poll numbers tanked he's
got very that's ways on the end and he
got NASA built an unbelievable company
worth billions and billions of dollars I
don't have to hear from this mission I
hope you apologize for that Donald wrong
we said no and that's the simple fact
the simple things up Jeff don't cut me
off come on don't make things and lastly
we don't want to forget the entertaining
exchanges between Donald Trump and Rand
Paul Donald Trump one of the most
outrageous candidates running for the
Republican nomination and Rand Paul
although I am no fan of Rand Paul's
probably one of the more reasonable
candidates they had a couple of
exchanges see I think you're on the
wrong side of this if you're still
arguing for a single play I'm not I'm
not I don't think you heard me you're
having a hard time tonight all right his
visceral response to attack people on
their appearance short tall fat ugly I
never attacked him on his look and
believe me this plenty of subject matter
right there that I can tell you Jake
Jake I want to give where do you stand
on the issue of birthright citizenship
well I hate to say it but Donald Trump
has a bit of a point here that's some of
the best of the Republican presidential
primary debates so far we'll keep
watching the debates and keep bringing
you the best and funniest moments